a bar in a courtyard in sokoto despite
Sharia law that is in force across the
city beer still flows freely and women
are chatting with men prostitution also
flourishes in the back rooms of the
building the bars owner whom will call
John prefers to remain anonymous because
he doesn't just provide the women with a
job he is also a people smuggler most of
them yes I came here because of the
economy
academic poem Sunday some of them you
know some of them they wanted to travel
to the south of the country you know our
son but let's barely lifting up at all
to go deeply to that the women also
didn't want to talk to us but a young
man refused to give his name as well did
he is planning to use John's help to
leave Nigeria who voiced over his
English when he passed you two years I
graduated two years ago and I'm still
without a job living from hand to mouth
so along with some friends I decided to
fulfill my dream and make something
positive out of my life I'll need
something positive a lack of perspective
and the dream of a better life that's
what motivates the growing amount of
people to embark on the dangerous
journey to Europe after long discussions
John agreed to tell us more about the
journey and his job as people trafficker
John takes us out on the very road he
took to smuggle more than 100 people in
Tunisia he is not afraid of the police
since they to profit from his business I
also grabbed my we are sometimes modem
and Jennifer Dodd yeah bugga the
megavision inland Tyrion the jailer
Medusa
so how much do they normally ask for
well they all said a dick they charge
back up up up up ahead sometimes 4,000 a
lot buy it 500 euros is what the
migrants page on so he can get them to
Libya he takes them as far as agadez
anuja there a colleague takes over John
said everyone who attempts to cross
knows of the danger barely half of them
make it to Europe he added he has no
qualms about his enterprise after all he
is not forcing anyone to come along you
know you make it all but I attempt
sometimes you may be killing it in the
any desert you know you may be robbed
that and it can be I if I love you can I
can't be left yes and I'm beside it I'll
only do that if you're keeping the vapor
get broke down you know so many people
use their you'd rather die on the road
because there's no mechanic closer to
the point where the cash boiled you are
trying to have this vision you know a
time some puff and you die on the bush
and the process does it is John says the
chaos in Libya means migrants have a
better chance of making it through the
country on the journey to what Europe
that's good news for him because it
means more customers in the coming month
even if he knows many of them will never
make it